all right let's do some audience
questions three great questions this
week the first of which is from jasmine
who said what genre of books do you guys
read I read a lot of different stuff I
mean you you've probably noticed that
it's a broad range from the
recommendations all sometimes do I read
a lot of fiction mostly at night this
includes crime fiction historical
fiction
I love cyberpunk and science fiction not
big into fantasy sometimes I tell people
I read sci-fi and they say have you led
the red the Lord of the Rings and I say
no I consider that fantasy although I
guess it's within science fiction but
I'm talking more about you know arthur c
clarke neal stephenson isaac asimov
although as a mob some of his stuff I
read less of it but some of some of his
stuff goes more in the direction of
fantasy philip k dick etc historical
fiction crime fiction what else it's
really pretty broad I'll read a popular
more literary fiction and a lot of
Italian and Japanese novels so for
fiction it's pretty broad and then for
nonfiction philosophy through I mean
what else philosophy from science I just
finished reading Carl Sagan's Cosmos I'm
reading Bertrand Russell's the history
of Western philosophy I recently picked
up you've all her Ari's new book homo
Deus which is the follow-up to sapiens
was the one that he previously wrote
it's really pretty broad I'm going to
start reading I just finished cosmos as
I mentioned I'm going to start reading
narcho na mcc's which is a basically
all-encompassing non-fiction book about
the drug cultivation and trade world
around the world so really a lot of
different stuff I don't know Pat if your
tastes are as broad as mine or even
broader sometimes I'll read you know
read Dostoevsky 19th century Russian
fiction all sorts of stuff really see
I'm really not one to get too caught up
into what genre the book is in I'm the
same way when it comes to music for me
it's more about do I like the story in
particular do I like the author and that
the mindset that they're coming through
and from that I mean I could like books
of a number of different
obviously there's some rules to that
like you know I'm not too big into
fantasy myself I tend to like
non-fiction books more than fiction
books and novels and stories for me
reading nonfiction and reading fiction
it's like it doesn't even relate like I
could read an hour of nonfiction and
sort of be fatigued from reading
nonfiction and then I'll go to bed 15
minutes later and I'll pull out my
fiction book and there's nothing that
translates from the fatigue of reading
nonfiction I jump right into my fiction
book like it's not even remotely the
same experience and that's why sometimes
for me it's surprising when people will
read fiction or nonfiction in bed before
falling asleep where I couldn't really
read nonfiction in bed I find that it
wakes me up it's not even close to the
same experience for me I think for some
people their eyes just get tired so
they're they're sick of looking at text
for a while but I understand because I
think you have to pay a lot more
attention when it comes to nonfiction
books because you're trying to take in
the information so you can kind of have
it in your memory and use it for later
but you know if you miss a key part of a
story obviously that's unfortunate but
it's not going to take away too much
from your experience what do you think
about that yeah I think I agree with
that
and it's just sort of taking in a story
as long as you have some minimum level
of attention that you're paying right
you're not that while you're reading
you're not reading totally mindlessly
it's probably easier to sort of be told
the fiction story then to sort of
integrate the non-fiction writing in a
way that is sort of meaningful and that
you'll remember I think I agree with
that although you may miss out on some
of the literary devices that they're
using so maybe there's some
foreshadowing that you don't recognize
because you're not completely invested
in the story yeah I agree with that also
a mystery I will read mystery is pretty
often but mystery often overlaps like
with crime fiction or with science
fiction or other other genres